been dealing with problems with my  health for a long time  and it's been really difficult for me to  face these challenges  and to talk about everything that I've  been going through have been diagnosed  with a very rare neurological disorder  called the stiff person syndrome  which affects something like  one in a million people I have no choice  but to concentrate on my health at this  moment  yeah wow I've never heard of this a  stiff person syndrome guys affects the  central nervous system it says  specifically the brain and spinal cord  patients can be disabled  wheelchair-bound or bedridden unable to  work or care for themselves and Celine  went on to say that you know that she's  working very hard with a sports medicine  therapist every day to build back her  strength her ability to perform again  but she says it's a struggle